I don't understand the game we pull this
off and it tells us what they're
searching like who's giggling okay we'll
find out right now watch this hey I'm
John Krasinski I'm Margot Robbie and I'm
session rainin
hi there it's Paul McCartney I'm Anna
Kendra and I'm Blake Lively I'm Aubrey
Plaza and I'm currently under a blanket
with Craig Robinson for this wired
autocomplete what is it see oh I knew I
just want you to autocomplete the answer
first one is Nick Kroll single Nick
Kroll is singularly focused on doing a
great job in this viral video are you
single
I am alone does armie hammer where does
he live by the way does army hammer is
even call you know it has to be asked
enough to make it to the list which
means that people are like does arming
hammer where does he live a lot who
looks like Evangeline Lilly just
recently I was mistaken for Julia
Roberts and I always think I see myself
in magazines and it turns out I flutter
myself because this Jennifer Garner I'm
gonna take this is the hugest compliment
like what is it what do you think is a
miracle
British no I'm actually American I've
just been flying the entire time I just
thought it'd be so much funnier if I
would just pretend to be British because
I think everyone's like smarter when
they're British how to pronounce Saoirse
Ronan it's actually it's so it's Saoirse
but it's easier for Americans and
English people to say Saoirse or Sasha
what was the difference
Saoirse is how Irish people say and how
two Americans
kind of okay did the Beatles wear wigs
and no we didn't wear wigs when we went
on The Ed Sullivan Show first appearance
on American TV all the dads who were
probably very jealous of these fine
heads of hair that we had and we were
shaking and doing things with them and
the dads of a lot of kids you saw the
wigs the wearing wigs oh no they were
talk to American ah
there were wigs hey they're wearing wigs
I have a very good Swedish tongue
twister for you guys who could go home
and try and say that about 20 times in a
row like a man who come I come yeah you
see it's it's a hard one I can say s
cause you're probably out toilette which
means can I use the bathroom which is
the only phrase I ever learned because I
was just trying to get at a French class
all the time yeah I know my cell
let me tell oh I don't know much yeah oh
I learned some today hey olan your
honest war Tama assitant Chewbacca solo
a Star Wars story Alchemist check
Michelle Akane hmm koko wa watashi meet
Coco I would toss cocoa while would
touch oh shoot does Jessie throat have a
dog hmm does justin theroux hug yeah
this was not planned look at this this
animal is maybe the laziest that's not
right now she hasn't moved
that's right she's not moved she's
ferocious hey guys he's gotta be named
by teamuk bites bites a lot and then we
ended up naming her Kumar shoe size odd
say your shoe size is something on the
lines of 29:27 I guess UK size 15 US
size 16 I'm full I'm in UK size 4
remember that time you took a nap in my
shoes when I was then I accidentally put
them on in your luggage
[Music]
did John Krasinski play lacrosse for one
day I don't know how this is a Google
search but I feel like you've been
spying on me since I was young but I
definitely suited up got a stick
got hit once and was like thanks for
playing everybody and I retired right
then there is Steven Yeun in the Jake
from State Farm commercial you know what
this is why we need more Asian people on
the everybody thinks I play all the
Asian people on television what do you
do with your free time
I don't watch your movies oh I didn't
see a pretty woman until 2000 no in the
top 2005 I never saw like 1938 yeah you
know I'm playing on a TV show right now
station 19 and the young actor Alberto
lights up it looks a lot like me hmm
watch that in 12 years I've watched a
lot of these videos I've been waiting
for this moment all my life I wasn't
sure if this was taper velcro and by the
way this isn't a wall I thought it was
gonna be a wall it's just a piece of
paper do people know that okay how does
Liza Coe she'd dance like this oh sorry
I hit the mic I'm so sorry about that
like this I'm not wearing a mic pack
what this is how my body moves this is
how I dance thank you for watching
does Anna Kendrick use auto-tune how
dare you how very dare yo yo that is
rude no I don't have I had to do more
than one take yes have I used auto-tune
yes and here we go
can rhettandlink oh we're getting to two
abilities can rhettandlink actually sing
[Music]
[Applause]
I can sing sing maybe far away or maybe
real nearby was it gonna be some
enchanted evening you may meet this
stranger la la la
dear Nick of it safe Nick :
yes it was fantastic and that is it
forward autocomplete I am Ken Jeong and
I really appreciate you having me can I
go now cut that part out